Ridley Scott's original alien movie
presents the really grounded view of the
future
this wasn't Holograms and touch screens
his Tonchi analog push-button technology
this is a world of CRT not LCD early in
development
our artist studied the work of Ron Cobb
who was one of the original concept
artists on the film and the goal was
that if we could understand his process
we would be able to expand on the
universe while still remaining faithful
to original source this lo-fi sci-fi
approach doesn't just inform the visuals
it also has a big effect on how we
design the gameplay if you take the
motion tracker for example it's big and
it's heavy and you can't hold it at the
same time as a weapon and all it does is
tell you the movement of an object on a
2d plane and even then only on a small
cone in front of you in all this s they
both fall to the sauce we set ourselves
a rule who wouldn't build anything that
couldn't have been built on the original
set in 1979 the first objective was to
strip back the UI as much as possible
for the on screen elements that we do
have we had to look at a lot of
different options to try and recreate
the softness and fuzziness that the
technology of the seventies presented
the technique that we found most
effective was actually to take gameplay
footage in UI elements and record them
onto VHS tape and play them back through
an old portable television and on its
way we would distort the cables and
stamp on the tape and generally destroy
equipment in the process once we got
that back into the game we found that it
then just look authentic it was
authentic this is a game says in the
future
the past it's a place which we can
really relate to it's also a world where
technology won't save you